GRIFF: NO COMMENT.
PETE: AT MY WEDDING ON THE DANCE
FLOOR UNBELIEVABLE:  PRESIDENT
TRUMP CALLING ON DEMOCRATS TO
GET BACK TO WORK OVER STANDOFF
MORE CASH FOR THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
LISTEN.
>> ESSENTIALLY WE’RE WAITING FOR
$250 BILLION THE DEMOCRATS ARE
REFUSING TO DO IT.
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY RELATIVE
TO WHAT IT REPRESENTS.
IT REPRESENTS SMALL BUSINESSES.
REPRESENTS THEM STAYING IN
BUSINESS.
IT’S SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
APPROVED BY THE DEMOCRATS.
THE REPUBLICANS WANT IT BADLY
AND THE PEOPLE WANT IT VERY
BADLY.
GRIFF: HERE TO REACT IS
CONGRESSMAN JOSH GOT JOSH GOTTHE
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
GRIFF: WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT THE PRESIDENT JUST SAID?
>> WE ALL WANT TO GET THE
PAYCHECK PROGRAM DONE AND THAT’S
THE LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAM FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES.
I HAVE BEEN TALKING TO SMALL
BUSINESSES DAY AND NIGHT.
WE HAVE GOT TO STAND BY THEM IN
NEW JERSEY WE HAVE BEEN HIT
INCREDIBLY HARD BY THE VIRUS.
I THINK WE ARE ALL ON BOARD.
THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE
ALSO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW.
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN HIT SO HARD NEW YORK
AND NEW JERSEY WE HAVE HALF THE
CASES IN THE COUNTRY.
OUR HOSPITALS ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING.
THEY ARE OUT OF RESOURCES.
AND OUR MUNICIPALITIES, OUR
TOWNS, OUR COUNTIES, THEY ARE
REALLY TAPPED OUT AND NEED HELP.
IN MY DISTRICT, JUST TO GIVE YOU
A SENSE OF IT.
WE HAVE GOT 20,000 CASES IN MY
IT THE AND MORE THAN 1,000
PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
IT’S REALLY A VERY ALARMING
SITUATION HERE.
JILLIAN: RESPECTFULLY,
CONGRESSMAN, IF EVERYONE IS ON
BOARD AS YOU SAY, WHY ISN’T IT
GETTING DONE?
>> WELL, MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF GOOD
CONVERSATION HAPPENING.
KEVIN McCARTHY YESTERDAY CAME
OUT AND SAID HE THINKS WE HAVE A
DEAL.
SO I’M HOPING THAT IT GETS DONE.
THERE IS NO REASON WHY IT’S NOT
GETTING DONE.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD, FRANKLY,
ABOUT COMING TOGETHER, DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS TO GET THE FIRST
EMERGENCY PACKAGES DONE TO HELP
THE COUNTRY AND HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET THIS DONE.
PETE: THERE IS A REASON IT’S NOT
GETTING DONE.
WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO RUN
OUT.
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN CALLING
FROM THE BEGINNING JUST
REPLENISH THIS PPP PROGRAM SO
SMALL BUSINESSES CAN GET IT.
YET, NANCY PELOSI, IN
CALIFORNIA, IS DEMANDING OTHER
SPENDING IN ADDITION TO IT.
THERE IS AN EASY SOLUTION, WHY
IS YOUR SPEAKER HOLDING OUT FOR
ADDITIONAL MONEY?
>> LISTEN, I SPEAK FOR MYSELF.
PETE: I KNOW, ABSOLUTELY.
>> I WILL JEWELS TELL YOU THAT
IF THEY HELD A VOTE, I’M THERE.
AND BUT MY POINT IS WE ALSO NEED
ASSURANCES IN -- FOR THE OTHER
AREAS THERE ARE SERIOUS CRISIS
HAPPENING IN DISTRICTS LIKE
MINE.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE ALSO
TAKE CARE OF OUR FRONT LINE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND AS YOU
KNOW IT’S BECAUSE YOU ARE RIGHT
IN THE AREA.
IT’S CRUSHING OUR STATES RIGHT
NOW.
WE NEED HELP.
NOT JUST, OF COURSE, FOR OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES BUT ALSO FOR
OUR FRONT LINE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS, FOR OUR HOSPITALS AND
FOR OUR TOWNS.
THE REALLY IN TOUGH TROUBLE
HERE.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN, SPEAKER
PELOSI WANTS, OBVIOUSLY, THIS
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR HOSPITALS,
FRONT LINE HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
AND THEN ALSO FOR THE STATES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE GOING
TO HAVE BUDGET PROBLEMS AND
SHORT FALLS HERE BUT THAT
PRESSING ISSUE THAT PETE IS JUST
ADDRESSING THERE IS THE REASON
WHY I’M GETTING EMAILS, MANY OF
US IN THE NEWS BUSINESS ARE,
FROM BUSINESS OWNERS SAYING I
APPLIED AND NOW THEY ARE SAYING
YOU ARE NOT -- THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO GIVE YOU THE LOAN
BECAUSE THEY CAN’T APPLY
ANYMORE.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, TAKE ME
PAST MONDAY MORNING, TUESDAY.
WHEN DO YOU SEE CONGRESS TAKING
ACTION?
>> I BELIEVE WE’RE GOING TO GET
A DEAL DONE AND I’M HOPING WE’RE
GOING TO GET A DEAL DONE THIS
WEEKEND AND VOTE NEXT WEEK.
THAT’S WHAT I’M HOPING FOR.
THAT’S WHAT WE ARE PUSHING FOR.
GRIFF: HAVE YOU BEEN TOLD THAT?
>> I HAVE BEEN TOLD -- I’M
READING WHAT YOU ARE READING.
I’M NOT IN THE NEGOTIATION.
BUT I KNOW WHAT WE ALL BELIEVE
STRONGLY WHICH IS WE ALL HAVE TO
GET THIS DONE.
WE ALL REPRESENT THESE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN NEED.
I KNOW I DO.
I WILL TELL YOU IT’S A HUGE
ISSUE.
ONE POINT WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT
TO GET MONEY TO OUR FRONT LINE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND HOSPITALS
AND NURSING HOMES.
IN THE CARES ACT THAT WAS
PASSED.
IN NEW JERSEY, IN MY DISTRICT
GETTING ABOUT $6,000 IN OUR
HOSPITALS PER PATIENT.
WHICH THE COSTS PEOPLE IN THE
HOSPITAL FOR WEEKS.
AND IF YOU GO TO WEST VIRGINIA.
THEY ARE GETTING MORE THAN
$400,000 PER PATIENT JUST THE
WAY THINGS WORKED OUT.
SO YOU CAN SEE WHY SOME AREAS
ARE GETTING CRUSHED AND WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS PUT THE RESOURCES
WHERE HAVE YOU GOT A HURRICANE
HITTING.
THAT’S WHAT WE HAVE ALWAYS DONE
WHEN THERE IS A NATURAL
DISASTER.
TRY TO HELP OUT THE AREAS HURT
MOST WHETHER THAT’S OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS OR OUR FRONT LINE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE WE
STAND BY THEM.
I THINK THAT’S WHAT -- I’M NOT
HEARING EVERYBODY UNDERSTAND
THAT IN THE COUNTRY.
AND I THINK IT’S REALLY
IMPORTANT THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
GOING THROUGH.
JILLIAN: WE WILL STAND BY THE
HOPE THIS DOES GET DONE.
YOU WERE NAMED TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP’S BIPARTISAN TASK FORCE
FOCUSED ON REOPENING THE
COMMUNITY?
REOPENING THE
ECONOMY.
WHAT IS IT GOING TO TAKE
EVERYONE, DO YOU THINK INTO THIS
PHASE ONE?
I KNOW IT’S GOING COB
INCREMENTAL FOR DIFFERENT
STATES.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR THE
PRESIDENT WHAT’S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE NEED A
BACK-TO-WORK CHECKLIST AS A WAY
TO COME -- REOPEN AMERICA AND
REOPEN COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE IN
A SAFE AND HEALTHY WAY.
AND WE -- YOU KNOW, AS WE ARE
DEALING WITH THE HEALTH CRISIS,
WE HAVE GOT TO DEAL WITH THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS AND MAKE SURE
POINT ON MAKING SURE OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE TAKEN CARE OF.
WE NEED A CLEAR CHECKLIST FOR
HOW YOU REOPEN.
WHAT NEEDS TO BE IN PLACE.
OF COURSE, TEST SOMETHING
ESSENTIAL TO THAT WE JUST DON’T
HAVE ENOUGH TESTING HERE AND
EVERY DAY I’M ON THE PHONE JUST
LIKE I’M ON THE PHONE WITH OUR
BUSINESSES AND FRONT LINE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND OTHERS
AND FIRST RESPONDERS SAYING
PLEASE, I NEED A TEST.
AND WE ARE REALLY STRUGGLING TO
GET THOSE TESTS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
HOSPITALS HAVE WHAT THEY NEED IF
THERE WAS AN OUTBREAK AGAIN WE
COULD HANDLE IT.
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
VENTILATORS, EVERYTHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE IN LINE.
AND ALSO VERY CLEAR INSTRUCTIONS
WITH HOW WE OPERATE OUR
BUSINESSES.
YOU KNOW, WHAT’S SAFE?
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE KEEP
PEOPLE HEALTHY IN THIS PROCESS?
THERE HAS GOT TO BE A VERY CLEAR
CHECKLIST.
WE HAVE GOT -- I CO-CHAIR A
GROUP CALLED THE PROBLEM
SOLVERS.
WE ARE PUTTING OUT A CHECKLIST
WHAT WE THINK NEEDS TO BE IN
PLACE TO REOPEN.
WE HAVE GOT TO DO IT IN A SAFE
WAY.
SHERIFF SHERIFF CONGRESSMAN, AS
YOU MENTION YOU ARE IN ONE OF
THE HARDEST HIT AREAS.
WE ARE THINKING ABOUT THE
RESIDENTS THERE THE PRESIDENT
SAID YESTERDAY SAFETY FIRST.
THAT’S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
AS WE LEARN MORE WE KNOW WHO IS
AFFECTED.
WE KNOW WHO THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ARE.
AS WE LEARN THAT INFORMATION
WITHIN THAT CONTEXT.
EVEN IN THE SOME OF THE HARDERS
HIT AREAS.
ISN’T THERE ROOM FOR SOME
LATITUDE FOR HEALTHY PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO TAKE THE PROPER SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS TO GO OUT AND OPEN
THEIR BUSINESS UP AS LONG AS
THEY PRACTICE THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND ARE RESPONSIBLE
ABOUT IT?
>> LISTEN, THAT’S AMONG THE
GUIDELINES WE ARE LOOKING FOR.
OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE AT THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL ARE SMARTER
THAN I AM ON THIS AND TELL US
EXACTLY WHAT WE CAN DO TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE.
I THINK A KEEP PART OF THAT AS
YOU WOULD AGREE IS TESTING.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO KNOW IF
SOMEONE HAS IT OR DOESN’T HAVE
IT BECAUSE THERE IS CARRIERS AND
YOU DON’T WANT TO FIND OUT THAT
YOU ARE SUDDENLY SPREADING IT
ALL OVER AGAIN AND GOT TO CLOSE
DOWN THE COUNTRY.
AGAIN, MY BIGGEST FEAR WOULD BE
THAT WE REOPEN AND THAT IT
SPREADS AGAIN AND WE HAVE GOT TO
SHUT IT DOWN AND DEVASTATING TO
THE ECONOMY AND DEVASTATING TO
THE COUNTRY THAT SO BADLY WANTS
TO OPEN.
I THINK HAVE YOU GOT TO DO IT IN
SMART FADES.
YOU HAVE GOT TO THINK OF COURSE
REGIONALLY AND THINK IN A SMART
WAY BY INDUSTRY.
BUT, LISTEN, I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO REOPEN QUICKLY.
I WANT THE KIDS TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
WE ALL WANT TO GET OUT OF THE
HOUSE.
WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID YESTERDAY WE DO
IT IN A VERY SAFE WAY.
PETE: REPRESENTATIVE JOSH